from a small town on the border between
Chad and Sudan friends and relatives of
people stuck in elginina try to offer a
lifeline
an informal network has sprung up
individuals working with drivers inside
Sudan trying to Ferry people out of
westar4
Ibrahim lives in Manchester but is from
al-janaina he's been in Audrey for two
weeks trying to get his family out
parents sister and children 15 relatives
in all
since the warning costume started I just
knew that West Africa to be particular
is going to be a chaos because the
situation in a Genera is really fragile
is filled with tribalism unable to make
contact at first he spent his time at
the border crossing waiting watching and
helping those he could
a sudden call just a slight issue people
who like there is some people need money
and I have to give them this money right
now okay a cash drop means someone else
makes it to safety every time I see
someone coming that gives me a hope
and if I saw someone that I I know or I
recognize give me
hope Joy doesn't have to be my family I
wish up like I pray for my family to get
to come right now but anyone who comes
out there from there it's just just give
me a hope speaking to people making it
out he says the reality in westar4 is
much worse than most people realize
bodies have lined the street for weeks
even fighters who began the conflict he
says are unable to escape
we learned just a few hours ago that
Muhammad's family did in fact make it
safely across the border from Sudan into
Chad they are now in Audrey and not a
moment too soon
just Days Later a new surge in violence
in Al Janina
those Crossing finding themselves on a
journey more deadly than it already was
Sudan border